Hey guys, another question that comes in quite often, especially in the late fall and in the
winter for certain niches, is you guys are seeing that your CPC is increasing. So let's say you set
it up and your CPC top page bid is like eight to nine dollars and all of a sudden November comes
around and you're noticing that it's like doubling or tripling in price. We do see this in concrete
a little bit. Definitely a big factor in tree service and part of those reasons is just
understanding these niches and understanding the cycle of those businesses. So I can tell you with
tree service, typically the best time to trim a tree and or remove a tree is going to be in the
fall and in the winter because the tree's not trying to grow, it's dying, it's kind of dead
and stagnant. It's the best time to have somebody come out and lop everything off and trim it up and
all that so that it has a better rebirth in spring. So those bids are going to be more
expensive because this is when people are calling to have that service done. So it's just about
competition, it's about Google making money, Google understanding the market space, but that's why we
talk about you get these people for all year and you'll see that wave. It'll go high, it'll go low,
but there's an average amount as well. So don't get too worried about it. If you see it go up,
you'll typically see things like tree service, concrete, like spray foam, things like that.
You'll see them come in in certain waves, but at the end of the year you'll kind of see that it
kind of averages out.